ça y est l'année 2021 a commencé pour
shiomi avec un nouveau modèle qui vient
d'arriver c'est le nouveau rémy note 9
pts je sais pas si vous êtes coutumier
de schumi mais chaque année il vous
sortent un nom de modèle c'est tellement
énorme qu'à la fin on finit un peu par
s'y perdre mais de notre côté il y en a
pour tout le monde à tous les prix avec
des techno qui sont intéressantes la
galère en 2020 ils ont continué à se
réinventer avec des smartphones très
haut de gamme les prix avaient augmenté
mais il était vraiment super bon en
photo en performance sur plein plein
plein plein de points et de l'autre côté
quand on arrive dans l'entrée milieu de
gamme et bien on retrouve aussi des
produits qui sont extrêmement séduisant
avec des renouvellements technologie est
là ce qui est super intéressant avec ce
nouveau smartphone avec ce raid min 9
qui est bien c'est que schumi vous
propose un smartphone 5g double sim 5 g
un tarif qui est extrêmement agressif
très intéressant donc on va faire
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on va faire un tour
complet de ce modèle il vient à peine
d'être présentée j'ai déjà en poche des
gens marieur die il est là et dans ma
poche et une magnifique on va donc
regarder ce qu'il peut vous apporter il
ya un tout nouveau processeur à
l'intérieur on va regarder si ce nouveau
processeur est intéressant et performant
s'il fonctionne bien oui ou non est
aussi nouvelle technologie lieu fès 2
points 2 je vais tout vous expliquer je
vais tous vous détail et surtout on va
se poser la question à la fin de voir si
c'est intéressant de venir se
positionner début 2021 sur un smartphone
5 g avec une double signe 5 jette ça
peut paraître séduisant mais est-ce que
derrière il ya des usages ya un intérêt
à ce que ça vaut le coup on va donc se
détailler tout de suite ce nouveau
smartphone mais avant toute chose vous
invite à venir vous abonner si ce n'est
pas déjà fait pour tout savoir sur la
culture parle de smartphone vous parle
de tablettes de montupet surtout de vous
de votre vie numérique je sais pas si
vous avez vu ce genre d'idée chose
aujourd'hui j'ai remis au goût du jour
le générique version 2021 et je
construis pour dire ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire
[Musique]
ça envoie du bois alors on va donc faire
tout complète de smartphones à commencer
par regarder le design au niveau de la
boîte ya pas grand chose à raconter
c'est un très grand classique comme vous
retrouver ici chez xiaomi avec quelques
petites choses du studio qui on passe
très rapidement parlera du bob de charge
dans quelques instants on enlève tout ça
et on fait venir le smartphone on est
vraiment dans l'adn de ces smartphones
d'entrée milliers de bienne avec un blog
photos qui au sens que vous avez trois
capteurs photo on regardera ça dans
quelques instants ici on va voir un dock
est en polycarbonate texture et le
polycarbonate textures et c'est en fait
du plastique si vous nous a vraiment
apporté cette texture qui va éviter de
laisser des traces de doigts en plus de
ça vous avez un côté un peu grippe sous
vos doigts ce qui fait que le smartphone
ne glisse pas on a une prise en main qui
est assez bonne pour trouver des coins
arrondis en haut mais également en bas
pour venir vraiment maximiser la prise
en main ici chez lui nous donne un
revêtement anti éclaboussures qui va
venir le protéger des gouttes de pluie
alors aussi ce qui est très rigolo c'est
qu'en fait vous n'avez pas de
certification pas certification ip68
1067 ça ce sont de certification qui
sont payantes on a donc aucune
certification sur ce smartphone mais
xiaot mélodies que s'ils rencontrent
quelques gouttes de pluie et bien vous
n'aurez aucun problème ne vous baignez
pas avec palmes dans une piscine pas
dans un verre d'eau rien du tout rien de
rien de rien d'autre de toutes façons de
smartphones n'est pas fait pour être mis
dans l'eau est allé se baigner avec dans
les eaux chlorelle et d'eau salée
néanmoins si vous êtes dans la rue qui
se met à pleuvoir normalement tout
devrait bien se passer vous avez trouvé
sur le côté ici un capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui permet de déverrouiller
qui fait office de bouton également ce
plutôt sympa plutôt bien positionner
votre bouton de volume on va retrouver à
l'avant ici un écran de 6,53 pouces full
hd + 2340 par 1080 pixels un écran qu'un
ratio 19 points 5/9 un verre corning
gorilla glass 5 pour vous le protéger à
l'avancé plutôt bien et surtout à
l'écran qui certifié tüv rheinland et
qui vient lutter contre la lumière bleue
vos smartphones est certifié whiteside
l1 qui nous permettra de faire tourner
netflix my canal disney + et consorts en
full hd ce smartphone qui est pas très
lourd qui en dessous des 200 grammes il
fait 199 g pour être extrêmement précis
en règle générale sur les smartphones
dans l'entrée milieu de gamme on
retrouve un seul haut parleur mono qui
se situe en bas sur le dessous on
s'attend à avoir dans cette gamme de
prix aux smartphones qui ne fait pas
tout ce qu'elle ne pourra pas tout à
boire et la chaumière fait une promo
quitterait intéressante c'est le fait de
se dire ok on va aller plus loin on va
mettre des haut parleurs stéréo vous
avez donc votre haut parleurs ici sur la
gauche qu'on connaît qu'on retrouve
usuellement et vous avez également un
haut parleur qui se situe ici en haut de
l'écran et ça c'est vachement
intéressant parce que ça apporte plus
d'immersion lorsque vous venez que
regarder du contenu multimédia regarder
un film allez sur vos différents réseaux
sociaux on va pas s'attendre à voir le
top qualité dans cette gamme de prix on
va voir un souk aient un peu tout fait
qui va me manquer de précision au niveau
des aigus et qui va venir saturé lorsque
vous mettez le son à fond par contre le
fait d'avoir ces deux haut parleurs
vient rajouter en immersion ça apporte
en confort au niveau de la
spatialisation même si d'un côté la
qualité est pas complètement dax si vous
voulez monter en qualité steve au fond
et bien c'est utiliser un casque avec
une prise jack parce que oui ici vous
avez une prise jack et si vous le
souhaitez vous pouvez également à péret
un casque en bluetooth grâce au
bluetooth 5 points autant vous dire que
vous avez un grand panel de choix comme
je le disais ici on un smartphone 5 g on
sait que la 5g commence à se
démocratiser arrive en france d'ailleurs
je sais pas si vous êtes en france dit
mon commentaire dans quel coin vous vous
situez ce que la 5g chez vous est ce que
vous avez un abonnement 5 g et est-ce
que potentiellement vous pensez en 2020
heures prendre un abonnement saint jean
marc et moi ça choque moins de voir ça
donc ici vous avez un smartphone qui
peut accueillir deux cartes sim 5 g
c'est toujours dans cette gamme de prix
de retrouver cette possibilité là ce qui
aurait elle atterrit aujourd'hui on va
regarder ça à la fin de la vidéo qui a
omis a mis le paquet au niveau des
technologies pour vous proposer
aujourd'hui sensiblement ce qu'on peut
faire mieux vous avez notamment la
technologie 4 x 4 mi mots qui vous
permettra de capter une meilleure bande
passante et d'améliorer le signale un
truc est pas mal c'est que vous avez
quatre antennes aux quatre coins de
votre smartphone ce que ça vous
permettra c'est que quelle que soit la
façon dont vous allez tenir en main bien
de pouvoir toujours capter le signal si
vous le tenez comme ça dans le bail bien
les antennes duo prendre le relais et là
où ça devient aussi intéressant c'est
qu'on va retrouver un tout nouveau
processeur qui vient à peine d'arriver
en france et qu'on trouve pour la
première fois dans ce smartphone c'est
un processeur de médiathèque c'est le
dit man city huit cents us vous avez ici
un score sur un toutou de 298 1651 ce
qui vous classe à la 29ème position en
dessous du samsung galaxy note 9 en
dessous du samsung galaxy s 9 plus mais
au dessus du renmin note suite pro est
au dessus du samsung galaxy s 9 et 10
minutes 10 ça c'est assez honnête c'est
un processeur gravé en 7 nanomètres qui
vous permettra d'apporter de la fluidité
qui fera tourner toutes vos applications
que ce soit vos jeux sur place tôt après
on va passer trop non plus avoir une
foudre de guerre une fois de plus dans
ce positionnement tarifaire mais
néanmoins il fonctionne très bien qui
fait tourner notamment asphalte 9 dessus
qui fonctionne bien différents types de
jeu il ya mis un peu de temps sur
asphalte 9 pour s'ouvrir vous allez
avoir ici quelques gigas de ram la
techno de ram c'est la lpddr2 4x c'est
un très grand stand a par contre ce qui
est neuf c'est la technologie vous allez
avoir pour l'écriture et la lecture en
gros le stockage de vos données on
connaissait usuellement lui fs 2.5 ou
retrouver dans cette gamme de
smartphones là on nous propose une
nouvelle techno qui était présenté l'été
dernier c'est lui fs deux points de
calais la grosse différence entre lui et
fès 2.20 élus ffs 2.2 ça toujours dans
le sens du progrès on va avoir un
smartphone qui va écrire plus vite vous
permettra de démarrer plus rapidement de
lancer des applications plus rapidement
autre pack est toujours mis en avant
dans les smartphones d'entrée et milieu
de gamme c'est l'autonomie avec une très
grosse batterie et ici chez aux mines
déroge pas à la règle avec une très
grosse batterie de 5000 milliampères
heures c'est le smartphone que vous avez
recharger ici en usb c est vous avez ce
gros bloc de charge de 22 points 5 watts
qui est inclus à l'intérieur il vous
permettra de le recharger en 18 watts
maximum soyez rassurez vous pouvez
brancher votre 22 et 25 quads pour
recharger en 18 watts maximum ça ne va
pas venir endommagé la batterie pas du
tout c'est optimiser c'est fait pour en
plus si robbie nous annonce que vous
n'aurez quasiment pas de dégradation au
niveau de l'autonomie de votre
smartphone pendant trois ans ce qui veut
donc dire que ce smartphone
potentiellement vous à pouvoir le garder
trois ans côté logiciel vous tournez sur
me wade 12 alors me wade où je voulais
déjà parlé je vous ai fait une vidéo
dédiée je vous invite à aller la
découvrir pour tout savoir - ouais 12e
bien l'expérience est bonne une fois de
plus je vous renvoie la vidéo que j'ai
déjà fait pour vous en parler comme ça
vous découvrirez tout sur les paramètres
les réglages des compagnies donc ça
c'est bien j'ai mis le lien mac dans la
description à l'aria vous trouvez trois
capteurs photo le premier vous trouvez
sur côté 148 mégapixels c'est votre
capteur principal c'est votre grand
temps que bref 1.79 sur l'autre partie
la partie de gauche vous avez deux
capteur de 2 mégapixels qui ouvre tous
les deux à f 2.4 celui du haut ses 14
profondeur qui est là pour les faits
boké et celui du dessous c'est le
capteur macro vous pouvez prendre des
photos jusqu'à 4 cm de distance tandis
qu'à l'avant et planck est juste là vous
avez une caméra de 13 mégapixels le
combo qu'on retrouve à l'arrière sont
ces trois capteurs c'est un peu pour
mettre de la poudre aux yeux de toute
façon aujourd'hui c'est une marque vous
sort un smartphone avec un seul capteur
vous n'allez pas forcément veut lâcheté
au dernier en date c'était google
c'était le pixel 3 qui avait un seul
capteur à l'arrière qui était très long
qui fonctionnait vraiment bien
aujourd'hui c'est un peu la course au
nombre de capteurs et on en veut pour
son argent où on en voit de plus en plus
donc ici chez tommy a fait le choix de
vous mettre trois capteurs le capteur
principal frappe pas on est sur le
capteur qui fonctionnera celui que vous
allez vraiment utilisé je ne suis pas
convaincu vous avez utilisé la macro
énormément je ne suis pas convaincu non
plus que le capteur profondeur vous
servent beaucoup considéraient ici est
derrière vous avez en réalité un capteur
vous allez utiliser et les deux autres
sont là pour être un peu plus gadget ça
va dans le sens du marketing c'est pour
raconter une jolie histoire vous avez un
vrai capteurs intéressant à l'arrière 7
48 mégapixels et le reste c'est pour
faire d'ailleurs dit moi si vous êtes
d'accord avec moi en bas en commentaire
ce qu'on va tout de suite c'est que sa
tendance un petit peu assure saturer les
couleurs pour rendre le rendu un peu
plus flatteur on le voit ici au niveau
du bois qui pèse quand même pas trop mal
le rouge ici le vert sort un petit peu
qu'on voit également c'est que ça avance
un petit peu a exacerbé les détails pour
rendre les photos plus nettes c'est un
peu poussif au niveau du traitement vous
le voyez derrière au niveau des petites
branches et vous le verrez également sur
d'autres photos on voit bien les détails
la voyez là sur le père noël qui sont
effectivement poussé par l algue aux
deux chiens ont mis en continu échec des
couleurs qui sont très cria très très
très très pétantes des très gros sur
cette photo parce que j'ai l'impression
qui a un côté un peu lisse et où ça
cherche à pousser les détails je pense
que le fait qu'ils aient de la neige à
complexifier la scène voyez toujours un
peu ce côté un peu p temps ici au niveau
des couleurs c'est un peu poussif au
niveau des détails globalement et vul
positionnement du smartphone c'est
plutôt pas mal gardé l'enfant devient le
détail en bas là je vous ai tenté un peu
de maquereaux une fois de plus la macro
je suis pas fan là dessus ça rajoute du
bruit au père luminosité il faut réussir
à ne pas bouger du tout parce qu'ici
vous n'avez absolument aucune
stabilisation il ya du bruit c'est pas
terrible je tentais différentes choses
et à chaque fois j'ai pas été
particulièrement conquis la caméra de
celle ci fonctionne pas trop mal c'est
pas complètement dingos mais malgré tout
le résultat reste relativement honnête
la macro une fois de plus soyez on voit
un petit peu les poils pour qu on
appelle ça un niveau 2 de la fleur mais
l'expo ehpad n'y a pas trop de détails
la colo change complètement lorna du
blanc l'ennui jaune bon pour moi c'est
une fois de plus oublié c'est
complètement brut en arrière-plan donc
pas terrible mais globalement ça me
donne rendu au niveau de la caméra
principale vu une fois de plus le
positionnement du smartphone je trouve
que le rendu est là que la qualité est
somme toute assez là même si c'est
poussif de par l'algo quant au mode
portrait bien il détour pas trop mal on
voit la puissance du processeur gravé en
7 nanomètres derrière donc ça vient vous
le découvrez c'est plutôt bien en termes
de cali s'est pas complètement dingue on
voit qu'on est des saturé par rapport au
capteur principal qui est lui par contre
un peu plus poussif la colorimétrie
n'est pas la même pour quelques
souvenirs en extérieur qu'on avait une
bonne luminosité pourquoi pas mais ne
vous attendez pas non plus à faire des
merveilles un smartphone équipé
également de nfc pour le paiement
dématérialisé et ce en période de
pandémie c'est pas mal comme ça on ne
touche pas on paye en dématérialisé
c'est très pratique google paye
fonctionnera très bien dessus sans aucun
problème en plus et je suis remis et un
des rares constructeurs à vous proposer
ça vous avez de l'infrarouge si vous
souhaitez utiliser votre smartphone
comme une télécommande vous pouvez le
faire qu'en médecine dentaire de tahiti
tout est là dessus j'ai fini par la
distillerie celle là vous avez donc deux
configurations soit 4 gigas de ram 64
giga de stockage soit 4 gigas de ram 128
giga de stockage la grosse différence
vous allez retrouver c'est que la
version 4 64 ou la retrouver uniquement
dans les mystères et sur me.com et il
coûtera 249 euros 90 si vous rajoutez 20
euros vous passez sur la version 428
vous doublez le stockage pour moi c'est
ce qu'il faut faire il faut lé là dessus
et là vous pouvez retrouver chez tous
les opérateurs enfin quasiment tous
bouygues orange sfr free et vous le
trouvez également dans le commerce nac
darty boulanger cdiscount rueducommerce
et ldlc à partir du 15 janvier dans tous
les cas d'ailleurs s'il vous intéresse
vous gagnez les liens en bas dans la
description ils apparaîtront à partir du
15 janvier parce qu'aujourd'hui vous
savez je tourne la vidéo c'est le jour
de l'annoncé je n'ai pas les voiles à
partir du 15 janvier votre voilier lien
en bas dans la description vous avez
vraiment ces 20 euros des cas donc je
vous recommande pas nécessairement
aujourd'hui de venir vous positionner
sur les versions 4 64 go de stockage
même si shinobi nous fait une promo à
lens an à 229 euros 90 pendant deux
jours du 15 au 17 64 go de stockage vous
risquez un moment de manquer un petit
peu autant rajouter ces 20 euros de plus
pour elle tout de suite sur les versions
qui aurait réellement intéressante c'est
la version 4 128 la question se pose
aujourd'hui c'est est-ce que c'est
intéressant aujourd'hui début 2021
d'aller se positionner un smartphone 5g
dans l'entrée milieu diane la 5g
commence tout juste à arriver en france
donc on va dire que tu n'es pas
nécessairement besoin et intérêts à
venir acheter un smartphone sans jamais
oser nous la question ce smartphone la
chaume et nous l'annoncent n'a pas avoir
de pertes et au niveau de la batterie
pendant trois ans à dire que
potentiellement c'est un smartphone que
vous avez gardé entre 2 et 3 ans en elle
le plus loin possible pour ne pas venir
gaspillé cinq fois plus que je te
d'important à dire et à sa barre dont
imaginons qu'on regarde trois ans c'est
l'idée on est début 2021 ça nous emmener
jusqu'à début 2011 24 peut-être que
début 2000 21me 2021 voir fin 2021 vous
ne verrez pas l'intérêt d'avoir un
smartphone 5g ça ne vous dérangera pas
avec l'émergence de la salle j y avoir
de plus en plus de services et
d'innovations et notamment au niveau du
cloud gaming va vraiment se démocratiser
aujourd'hui c'est un des usages majeur
sur smartphone c'est le jeu c'est un des
enjeux majeurs tout le monde se
positionne dessus et tout le monde
cherche à draguer les joueurs sur
smartphone hawks est évident que les
services de cloud gaming grâce à la 5g
vont exploser vous êtes donc avoir
probablement beaucoup plus d'offres
court en 2021 voire 2022 donc arrivera
un moment potentiellement en 2022 vous
allez vouloir avoir de la santé pour
pouvoir bénéficier des services de cloud
gaming notamment donc ça serait dommage
aujourd'hui vu le positionnement
tarifaire à 269 euros de ne pas venir
vous positionner sur un smartphone 5 g
vous pouvez trouver toujours le chiot
mis leurs ennemis note 9 ou leur
éminente neuf pros qui sont deux
smartphones pas mal intéressant de
l'année dernière mais qui sont des
smartphones 4g dont petit train mettre
cette somme aujourd'hui en 2021 autant
le faire sur un smartphone 5j en tout
cas c'est mon avis dites moi vous ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire et
quant à nous on se retrouve très vite
très très vite pour continuer à parler
de teck allez bisous l'amour et à très
vite